here brown here with another GameSpot
news update today Blizzard announced
today will be releasing the ultimate
evil edition of Diablo 3 on consoles
this august this version of the game
includes both the core Diablo 3 game and
the Reaper of souls expansion previously
only confirmed for PlayStation 4 it will
be available for both PlayStation 4 and
Xbox one for an estimated $60 and for
ps3 and xbox 360 for a modest $40
there will be an apprentice mode that
boosts low-level players so that they
can play co-op with their high-level
buddies and a new in-game mail system
that allows you to share Luke with your
friends pre-orders and launch day copies
will come with an in-game item infernal
pauldrons which gives bonuses to help
life regeneration and cooldown reduction
players will be able to transfer their
xbox 360 or Playstation 3 characters to
the new addition and they will also be
able to transfer PlayStation 3
characters to PlayStation 4 and Xbox 360
characters to the Xbox one version of
ultimate evil edition
however as before console players will
be unable to team up with their PC
compatriots and you will be unable to
transfer characters from PC to console
diablo 3 reaper of souls ultimate evil
edition comes out for consoles August
19th more updates on the game stay tuned
to game spot calm